The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right.
As everyone finishes getting
settled in, why don't you take
10 more seconds on the clicker
question here, and let's see
how you did on that this, this
is very similar to the clicker
question that we
had on Friday.
OK, so let's get started here.
It looks like we are
doing a lot better.
We now have 77% getting the
correct answer, we only had
about 30-something percent
on Friday for a
very similar question.
So if you're not in this 77%,
let's quickly go over why, in
fact, this is the correct
answer, 0 .
9 times 10 to the negative
18 joules.
So I'm using the same kind of
tricky language that we'd used
before, not to trick you, but so
that you're not tricked in
the future.
So if we're talking about the
fourth excited state, and we
talk instead about principle
quantum numbers, what
principle quantum number
corresponds to the fourth
excited state of a
hydrogen atom.
STUDENT: Five.
PROFESSOR: Five.
OK.
So, hopefully that cleared up
for some of you why you got
the wrong answer.
So we know that we're in the n
equals 5 state, so we can find
what the binding
energy is here.
The ionization energy, of
course, is just the negative
of the binding energy.
We know that binding energy is
always negative, we know that
ionization energy is
always positive.
So hopefully, putting all those
things together, if you
looked at this question again
we'd get 100% on it, that our
only option here is 0 .
9, and that it's not the
negative, it's the positive
version, because we're talking
about how much energy we have
to put into the system in order
to eject an electron.
All right.
And today we're going to mostly
be talking about wave
functions of electrons, but
before we get to that, I
wanted to review one last
thing that's back on to
Friday's topic, which was
when we were solving the
Schrodinger equation, or in
fact, using the solution to
the Schrodinger equation for the
energy, the binding energy
between an electron
and a nucleus.
And when we talked about that,
what we found was that we
could actually validate our
predicted binding energies by
looking at the emission spectra
of the hydrogen atom,
which is what we did as the
demo, or we could think about
the absorption spectra
as well.
And what we predict as an energy
difference between two
levels, we know should
correspond to the energy of
light that's either emitted, if
we're giving off a photon,
or that's absorbed if we're
going to take on a photon and
jump from a lower to a
higher energy level.
So we came up with two formulas,
which are similar to
the two that I'm showing here.
The formula tells us the
frequency of the light that's
emitted or absorbed based on the
energy difference between
the two levels that we're
going between, that the
electron is transitioning
between.
You'll notice that there's a
little bit of a difference in
these equations here from the
ones from the other day, which
is that you have this z squared
value in there.
So these are both called Rydberg
formulas for figuring
out the frequency of light
emitted or absorbed, and
before we were looking at the
Rydberg formula specifically
for the hydrogen atom, and now
that we have this z squared
term in the formula here,
we're now talking about
absolutely any one
electron atom.
And it should make sense where
we got this from, because we
know that the binding energy,
if we're talking about a
hydrogen atom, what is the
binding energy equal to?
Negative Rydberg over what?
Yes.
So, it's negative Rydberg
constant over n squared.
But if we're talking more
generally about any one
electron atom, now we have a
more general equation for the
binding energy, which has this z
squared term out in front of
it, right, so it's negative z
squared times the Rydberg
constant all over n squared.
So, essentially when we're
talking about these equations
up here, all we're doing is
talking about the regular
Rydberg formulas, but instead we
could go back and re-derive
the equation for any one
electron atom, which would
just mean that we put that z
squared term in the front.
So when you solve certain types
of problems, such as
problems later on in the second
half of your p-set, if
you need to talk about the
frequency of light emitted or
absorbed for a one electron
atom, such as lithium plus 2,
for example, then you would
need to plug in z, and
remember the z value for lithium
would just be 3.
The z value for hydrogen, of
course, is 1, and that's why
this term falls out of that
equation when we're talking
specifically about the
hydrogen atom.
So, just to finish our review
of what we talked about on
Friday, when we're thinking
about transitions between two
different states, and we're
talking about a situation
where the final state, the n
final, is greater than n
initial, in this case, are we
talking about absorption or
are we talking about emission?
Hearing a little bit
of a mix here.
In fact, we're talking about
absorption when n final is
greater than n initial.
We start at this lower energy
state and go up -- that means
we need to absorb a photon,
we have to take in energy.
Specifically, we have to take in
this exact amount of energy
in order to bump the electron up
to the higher energy level.
So that means that when instead
we start high and go
low, we're dealing with emission
where we have excess
energy that the electron's
giving off, and that energy is
going to be equal the energy of
the photon that is released
and, of course, through our
equations we know how to get
from energy to frequency or to
wavelength of the photon that
we're talking about.
All right.
So that's all I'm going to say
today in terms of solving the
energy part of the Schrodinger
equation, so what we're really
going to focus on is the other
part of the Schrodinger
equation today, which
is solving for psi.
So we're going to for psi, and
before that, we're going to
figure out that instead of just
that one quantum number
n, we're going to have a few
other quantum numbers that
fall out of solving the
Schrodinger equation
for what psi is.
We're also going to talk more
about what psi actually means.
When we first introduced the
Schrodinger equation, what I
told you was think of psi as
being some representation of
what an electron is.
We'll get more specific here,
more specific even than just
saying you can think of
it as an orbital.
We'll really think about
what psi means.
And in doing that, we'll also
talk about the shapes of h
atom wave functions,
specifically the shapes of
orbitals, and then something
called radial probability
distribution, which will make
sense when we get to it.
But, as I said before that, we
have some more quantum numbers
to take care of, because it
turns out that when you solve
the Schrodinger equation for
psi, these other quantum
numbers have to be
the defined.
When we talked about binding
energy, we just had one
quantum number that
came out of it.
And that quantum number was
n, which was our principle
quantum number, and we know that
n could be equal to any
integer value, so, 1, 2, 3, all
the way up to infinity.
And this quantization that comes
out of having n is what
gives us the quantization of
different energy levels.
That's why we can't have a
continuum of energy, we
actually have those
quantized points.
So, it turns out that n is not
the only quantum number needed
to describe a wave function,
however.
There's two more that you
can see come out of it.
And the first is l, and l is our
angular momentum quantum
number, and it's called that
because it actually dictates
the angular momentum that our
electron has in our atom.
And when we talk about l it is
a quantum number, so because
it's a quantum number, we know
that it can only have discreet
values, it can't just be any
value we want, it's very
specific values.
And unlike n, l can start all
the way down at 0, and it
increases by integer value,
so we go 1, 2, 3,
and all the way up.
But also unlike n, l cannot have
just any value, we can't
go into infinity.
L is limited such that
the highest value of
l is n minus 1.
We can't get any higher
than that.
So, it would be a good question
to ask why are we
limited -- clearly there's this
relationship between l
and n, and we can't get any
higher than n equals one.
We can actually think about why
that is, and the reason is
because l is our angular
momentum.
It describes the angular
momentum of the electron.
So another way to think about
that is just the rotational
kinetic energy of
our electron.
And we know that n describes the
total energy, that total
binding energy of the electron,
so the total energy
is going to be equal
to potential energy
plus kinetic energy.
So if we say that l is just
talking about our kinetic
energy part, our rotational
kinetic energy, and we know
that electrons have potential
energy, then it makes sense
that l, in fact, can never
go higher than n.
And, in fact, it can't even
reach n, because then we would
have no potential energy at all
in our electron, which is
not correct.
So, that's the second
quantum number.
And the third one is called
m, it's also m sub l.
This is what we call the
magnetic quantum number, and
we won't deal with the fact of
its being the magnetic quantum
number here -- that kind of
tells us the shape of the
orbital or the way that the
electron will behave in a
magnetic field, but what's
more relevant to thinking
about the limits of this number
is that it's also the z
component of the angular
momentum.
So since it's a component of
the angular momentum, that
means that it's never going to
be able to go higher than l
is, so it makes sense that, for
example, it could start at
0 and then go all
the way up to l.
But since it is a component it
can have a direction, too, so
can go up between negative
l and positive l.
So the allowed values for m sub
l are going to be negative
l, all the way up to 0, and
then up to positive l.
So, if we think of just an
example, we could say that 4 l
equals 2, what would be our
lowest value of m sub l?
Yup.
So m sub l could equal
negative 2,
negative 1, 0, 1 or 2.
So we could have five different
values of m sub l.
So, those are our three
quantum numbers.
So if, in fact, we want to
describe a wave function, we
know that we need to describe
it in terms of all three
quantum numbers, and also as
a function of our three
positional factors, which are
r, the radius, plus the two
angles, theta and phi.
So, we have now a complete
description of a wave function
that we can talk about.
So, we can think about what is
it that we would call the
ground state wave function.
We knew from Friday, when we
talked about energy, that
ground state was that n equals
1 value, that was the lowest
energy, that was the most
stable place for
the electron to be.
But now we need to talk
about l and m as well.
So now when we talk about a
ground state in terms of wave
function, we need to talk about
the wave function of 1,
0, 0, and again, as a function
of r, theta and phi.
So this is our complete
description of the ground
state wave function.
So, a lot of you talked about
different types of orbitals in
high school, I'm sure, or in
previous courses, and it might
be less common that you actually
talked about a wave
function that was labeled
like this.
We're used to labelling orbitals
as an s, or a p, or a
d, for example, but it turns
out that these correlate to
those letters that we're
more used to seeing.
Does anyone know what the 1, 0,
0 orbital is also called?
Yeah.
And specfically it's the
1 s, so not just the
s, but the 1 s orbital.
So, using the terminology of
chemists, which is a good
thing to do, because in this
course we are all chemists, we
want to make sure that we're
not using just the physical
description of the numbers, but
that we can correlate it
to what we understand as
orbitals, and instead of 1, 0,
0, we call this the
1 s orbital.
The reason that we do this is
because this is another way to
completely describe it.
The n designates the shell, so
that's what this number is
here, we're in the
first shell.
The l is what we call
the sub shell.
And instead of having
a 0 there, what we
have here is an s.
So, if we look at what the other
sub shells are called,
essentially we're
just converting
the number to a letter.
L equals 0 is s, what
is l equals 1?
Um-hmm, it's the p.
What about 2? d, and 3?
Yup, so 3 is f.
So these names, they don't
really make any sense if we're
looking at them why they're
called past s p and f, and it
turns out that it comes from
spectroscopy terms that are
pre-quantum mechanics where,
for example, this is called
the sharp line, I think the
principle, the diffuse, and
the fundamental.
It doesn't even make sense
now, they're not used in
spectroscopy anymore, but this
is where the names originally
came from and they did stick.
So, we being chemists, we'll
call that 1 s instead of 1, 0.
In addition to having another
name to denote l, we also have
another name for the
m designation here.
So, for example, when l is equal
to 0, we're going to
find that we have to call
-- we have to specify
what m is as well.
All right.
So, when we have, for example,
l equal to 1, what kind of
orbital is this?
The p orbital.
And for example, we could
also in this case, have
m is equal to 0.
If m is equal to 0, in this case
we would call it the p z
orbital, so we would have
the subscript z here.
Similarly, if m is equal to
either plus 1 or minus 1, we
would in turn call it the p y
orbital, or the p x orbital.
So you should know that any time
m is equal to zero when
we are talking about p orbitals,
that it's the p z.
The p y and the p x are
actually a bit more
complicated, they're linear
combinations of the m plus 1,
and the m minus 1 orbital, where
1 is the positive linear
combination, and 1 is the
negative linear combination.
You're not responsible for that,
you're not responsible
for correlating plus 1
to y, minus 1 to x.
Just know that you have plus or
minus 1, for our class, you
can call it either x or y,
either is fine, because it's a
little bit more complicated than
just the 1:1 translation
between, for example, m equals
0 and having a p z orbital.
All right.
So let's look at some of these
wave functions and make sure
that we know how to name all of
them in terms of orbitals
and not just in terms
of their numbers.
Once we can do that we can go on
and say okay, what actually
is a wave function, but first
we need to know how to
describe which ones were
talking about.
So we saw that our lowest,
our ground state wave
function is 1, 0, 0.
We can call that psi 1,
0, 0 is how we write
it as a wave function.
We said that's the
1 s orbital.
We also know how to figure out
the energy of this orbital,
and we know how to figure out
the energy using this formula
here, which was the binding
energy, which is negative r h,
and instead of n, we can plug
it in because n equals 1, so
over 1 squared, and the
actual energy is here.
So, our next level up that we
can go is going to be the n
equals 2 energy level, but we
also have an l and an m value,
so our lowest l is going
to be a 0 there.
So we'll call that psi 2,
0, 0 wave function.
What will we call that
in terms of orbitals?
Yup, so that's the
2 s orbital.
So something I actually wanted
to point out that I forgot to
here is you'll notice that
there's no subscript to the s.
We said we have a subscript to
the p, for example, that
describes what m is equal to.
The reason that we have no
subscript to the s, is because
the only possibility for m when
you have an s orbital is
that m has to be equal to 0.
So we just assume it, you don't
actually have to write
it because there is, in fact,
only one possibility.
We can also figure out the
energy of this orbital here,
and the energy is equal to
the Rydberg constant.
The negative of the Rydberg
constant now
divided by 2 squared.
So we can go on and do this for
any orbital or any state
function that we
would like to.
So, for example, if we talk
about the 2, 1, 1 state label,
that's just psi 2, 1, 1.
What, in this case, would
be our orbital?
2 p what?
OK, good, I heard mixed answers,
which is correct.
So you can either write 2 p x
or 2 p y, whichever one you
want is fine.
And again, you'll notice that
our energy is absolutely the
same for an electron in
that 2 p x orbital
and in the 2 s orbital.
So that's true for a hydrogen
atom, it doesn't matter if
you're in a p or an s orbital,
their energies are the same.
Then we can also talk about the
2, 1, 0 state function,
which would be psi 2, 1, 0.
What is this orbital?
Yup.
And there's only one correct
answer here,
which is to 2 p z.
Is the energy going to be the
same or different as up here?
It's going to be the
same energy.
Again, the reason for that is
because the energy only
depends on the n value
here, it doesn't
depend on l or on m.
So finally, if we talk about our
last example of when n is
going to be equal 2, we can
have 2, 1 for l and
then minus 1 for m.
We can re-write this as
psi 2 1 negative 1.
And then our orbital is going
to be just the opposite of
whatever we said
it was up here.
So if you said 2 p x the first
time, say 2 p y this time.
And again, our energy is going
to be the same where we again
only depend on the n value.
All right.
So hopefully we're pretty
comfortable naming any type of
wave function using the
chemist terminology.
Let's switch to a clicker
question and just confirm that
that is, in fact, true.
So what's the corresponding
orbital if we talk about this
state, 5, 1, 0?
And you can go ahead and give
10 seconds on that.
OK.
All right, 77%.
So, that's OK, you don't have to
memorize things as I speak,
you just need to go back and
look at this and make sure you
understand how to name it and
that you'll be able to, for
example, by next class, get
a similar clicker question
correct, and good job to the
77% that did get it.
So I think we're safe
to move on here.
And I just want to point out
that now we have these three
quantum numbers.
The reason there are three
quantum numbers is we're
describing an orbital in three
dimensions, so it makes sense
that we would need to describe
in terms of three different
quantum numbers.
And the complete description, as
I said, is from n l and m.
And when you talk about n for an
orbital, it's talking about
the shell -- that shell is kind
of what you picture when
you think of a classical picture
of an atom where you
have 1 energy level, the next
one is further out, the next
one's further away.
That's kind of your shell
that we're discussing.
L is the sub shell here, and
then we have m, which is
finally the complete description
of the orbital.
And what you can see is that for
any n that has an l equals
0, you can see here how there's
only one possibility
for and orbital description, and
that's why we don't need
to include the m when we're
talking about and s orbital.
The other thing that we know,
which is what we were just
discussing when we were going
through the table is how this
all relates to energy.
And I want to really highlight
here we're talking about for a
hydrogen atom -- orbitals
with the same n value
have the same energy.
Some of you might be saying in
your heads, wait a second, I
happen to know, I happen to
remember from high school,
that p orbitals have different
energies then,
for example, s orbitals.
And that is not true for one
electron atoms. We're going to
get to more complicated atoms
eventually where we're going
to have more than one electron
in it, but when we're talking
about a single electron atom,
we know that the binding
energy is equal to the negative
of the Rydberg
constant over n squared, so
it's only depends on n.
So, for example, if we're
talking about the n equals 2
state, all of these four orbital
descriptions are going
to have the same energy.
And we can generalize to figure
out, based on any
principle quantum number n, how
many orbitals we have of
the same energy, and what we can
say is that for any shell
n, there are n squared
degenerate orbitals.
And the word degenerate simply
means same energy, so you have
n squared orbitals that are of
equal energy when they're
degenerate.
So, let's look at where this
comes from with an energy
level diagram here.
So what you can see is again,
we've got this ground state.
So if we go to the ground state,
what you see is we're
at that lowest energy level,
and we only have one
possibility for an orbital,
because when n equals 1,
that's all we can do.
So that's the 1 s orbital --
we have n squared or 1
degenerate orbitals.
When we talk about the n equals
2 state, we now have 2
squared or 4 degenerate same
energy orbitals, and those are
the 2 s orbital.
And then we also have the l
being equal to 1 orbital, so
those are going to be the
2 p x, the 2 p z,
and the 2 p y orbital.
All four of these orbitals have
the same energy, they're
degenerate.
And as we go up the next energy
level, which is based
on n equals 3 principle quantum
number, well now we
have again the s, so we have the
3 s orbital, we're going
to have three 3 p orbitals,
right, so we'll have 3 p x, 3
p z, and 3 p y, and now we're
actually also going to have
five different possible
l equals 2 orbitals.
Does anyone remember
the l equals 2?
Yes, everyone remembers.
Good.
So we have five possible
d orbitals.
We'll call these here the 3 d x
y, as the subscript, the 3 d
y z, the 3 d z squared, the 3
d x z, and the 3 d x squared
minus y squared.
So, what do you need
to know here?
What you need to know is
that when m equals
0, it's 3 d z squared.
That's it.
Again, these other p -- or the
d x y, d y z, those are going
to be those more complicated
linear combinations, you don't
need to worry about them.
Eventually you will, at least,
need to know the labels and
know a little bit
more about them.
And in the second half of this
course, Professor Drennen's
going to talk to us about
transition metals in depth,
and that's when we'll really
delve into d orbitals.
For right now, you can kind of
put the d orbitals in the back
of your head.
You need to know how to think
about them in the same way we
think about s and p orbitals,
but for example, you don't yet
need to know what all of the
names are except for this 3 d
z squared here.
So we'll wait on that until
we start talking more
specifically about atoms where
the d orbital becomes very
significant.
So, what we can see is
this degeneracy.
So what we know now is we can
start thinking about the next
step because we can fully
describe the energy of
orbitals, and we can fully
describe a complete orbital in
terms of its three quantum
numbers, and its three
positional variables,
r, theta, and phi.
So next we can think about okay,
what is actually a wave
function, and for example,
what might the shape of
different wave functions be.
So essentially, what we're
asking for here is the
physical interpretation of psi,
of the value of psi for
an electron.
And it turns out that the answer
to can we have this
physical interpretation of
thinking about what psi means,
the answer is really
no, that we can't.
There's no classical way to
think about what a wave
function is.
There's no classical analogy
that explains oh, this is what
you can kind of picture when you
picture a wave function.
And that's somewhat inconvenient
because we're
working with wave functions, but
it's a reality that comes
out of quantum mechanics often,
which is that we're
describing a world that is so
much different from the world
that we observe on a day-to-day
basis, that we're
not always going to
be able to make
those one-to-one analogies.
But luckily we don't have to
worry about how we're going to
picture all this, now that I
said that, because even though
there's no physical
interpretation for what a wave
function is, there is a physical
interpretation for
what a wave function
squared means.
So when we talk about a wave
function squared, we're taking
the square of the wave function,
any one that we
specify between n, l and m, at
any position that we specify
based on r, theta, and phi.
And if we go ahead and square
that, then what we get is a
probability density, and
specifically it's the
probability of finding an
electron in a certain small
defined volume away
from the nucleus.
So it's a probability density.
The important point here is it's
not just a probability,
it's a density, so we know
that it's a probability
divided by volume.
And the person we have to thank
for actually giving us
this more concrete way to
think about what a wave
function squared is
is Max Born here.
And actually after the
Schrodinger equation first was
put forth, people had a lot of
discussions about how is it
that we can actually interpret
what this wave function means,
and a lot of ideas were put
forth, and none of them worked
out to match up with
observations until Max Born
here came up with the idea that
we just square the wave
function, and that's the
probability density of finding
an electron in a certain
defined volume.
And it's very helpful because
it gives us a way
to think about it.
We can't actually go ahead and
derive this equation of the
wave function squared, because
no one ever derived it, it's
just an interpretation, but it's
an interpretation that
works essentially perfectly.
Ever since this was first
proposed, there has never been
any observations that do not
coincide with the idea, that
did not match the fact that
the probability density is
equal to the wave function
squared.
So, also about Max Born, just to
give you a little bit of a
trivial pursuit type knowledge,
he not only gave us
this relationship between wave
function squared, he also gave
us Olivia Newton-John.
This is her grandfather, I don't
know if you can see from
the eyes, I feel like there's
a little bit of
a resemblance there.
So, I don't know what she grew
up hearing about when she went
to her grandparents' house, but
it might have been wave
function squared.
So, a little tidbit of knowledge
for you that's
somewhat trivial.
Then back to the non-trivial
knowledge that is not trivial
at all, in fact, is OK, how
do we think about this
probability density now
that we have a little
bit more of an idea.
We know that it's a density,
it's not an actual
probability.
So, one way we could look at
it is by looking at this
density dot diagram, where the
density of the dots correlates
to the probability density.
So, what you see is near the
nucleus, the density is the
strongest, the dots are
closest together.
As you get far away from the
nucleus, the dots get farther
and farther apart, meaning the
probability density at those
volumes far away from the
nucleus is going to be quite
low, eventually going to almost
zero, although it turns
out that it never goes to
exactly zero, so if we're
talking about any orbital or
any atom, it never actually
ends, it never goes to zerio.
But it turns out the
probability is only
significant within
one angstrom.
So you can either say that
electrons are very, very tiny
or that they're never ending,
and both are pretty accurate
ways to think about
what an atom is.
So, that's probability density,
but in terms of
thinking about it in terms of
actual solutions to the wave
function, let's take a little
bit of a step back here.
I have yet to show you the
solution to a wave function
for the hydrogen atom, so let
me do that here, and then
we'll build back up to
probability densities, and it
turns out that if we're
talking about any wave
function, we can actually
break it up into two
components, which are called the
radial wave function and
angular wave function.
So, essentially we're just
breaking it up into two parts
that can be separated, and the
part that is only dealing with
the radius, so it's only a
function of the radius of the
electron from the nucleus.
And we abbreviate that by
calling it r, which is
specified by two quantum
numbers, and an l as a
function of little r, radius.
And we have the angular wave
function, which is specified
by l and m, and it's a function
of the two angles
when we're describing the
position of the electron, so
theta and phi.
So, let's look at what this
actually is for what we're
showing here is the
1 s hydrogen atom.
If you look in your book there's
a whole table of
different solutions to the
Schrodinger equation for
several different
wave functions.
So this is the 1 s, you can
look it up if you're
interested for the 2 s, or 3 s,
or 5 s, or whatever you're
curious about.
But what I'm going to show you
here is the 1 s solution.
So you can see there's this
radial part here, and you have
the angular part, you can
combine the two parts to get
the total wave function.
And what you can see is we have
this new constant that we
haven't seen before.
So what do you see in
there that is new?
Yeah.
This a sub nought.
That's a new constant for
us in this course.
This is what's called the Bohr
radius, and we'll explain --
hopefully we'll get to it today
where this Bohr radius
name comes from, but for now
what you need to know is just
that it's a constant, just treat
it like a constant, and
it turns out to be
equal to 52 .
9 pekameters or about
1/2 an angstrom.
The more important thing that
I want you to notice when
you're looking at this wave
equation for a 1 s h atom, is
the fact that if you look at the
angular component of the
wave function, you'll notice
that it's a constant.
It doesn't depend on theta,
it doesn't depend on phi.
No matter where you specify your
electron is in terms of
those two angles, it doesn't
matter the angular part of
your wave function is going
to be the same.
So, what does that
mean for us?
Well, essentially what that
tells is that these s orbitals
are spherically symmetrical.
That should make sense, right,
because they're only
dependent on r.
How far you are away from the
nucleus in terms of a radius,
they don't depend at all on
those two angles, they're
independent of theta and they're
independent of phi.
So, what I'm showing in this
picture here is just an
electron cloud that
you can see.
Think of it as a probability
density plot.
And what here is just a graph of
the 1 s wave function going
across some radius defined this
way, and you can see that
the probability -- well, this
is the wave function, so we
would have to square it and
think about the probability.
So this squared at the origin
is going to be a very high
probability, and it decays off
as you get farther and farther
away from the nucleus or from
the center, and that's
independent of the angle.
So, let's look at these
probability plots of different
s orbitals here, and up top
here, we have the probability
density plot and what you can
see is what I just said, a
very high probability density
in the nucleus,
decays as you go out.
And what is plotted below is the
actual wave function, so
you can see it starts very high
and then the decays down.
More interesting is to look
at the 2 s wave function.
So, if we look at the bottom
here and the actual plot of
the wave function, we see it
starts high, very positive,
and it goes down and it
eventually hits zero, and goes
through zero and then becomes
negative and then never quite
hits zero again, although
it approaches zero.
So, at this place where it hits
zero, that means that the
square of the wave function is
also going to be zero, right.
So we can see if we look at the
probability density plot,
we can see there's a place where
the probability density
of finding an electron anywhere
there is actually
going to be zero.
So we can think of a third case
where we have the 3 s
orbital, and in the 3 s orbital
we see something
similar, we start high, we go
through zero, where there will
now be zero probability density,
as we can see in the
in the density plot graph.
Then we go negative and we go
through zero again, which
correlates to the second area of
zero, that shows up also in
our probability density plot,
and then we're positive again
and approach zero as we
go to infinity for r.
So, what this means is that
when we're looking at an
actual wave function, we're
treating it as a wave, right,
so waves can have both
magnitude, but they can also
have a direction,
so they can be
either positive or negative.
So, for example, if we were
looking at the actual wave
function, we would say that
these parts here have a
positive amplitude,
and in here we
have a negative amplitude.
And when we're looking at the
probability density graphs, it
doesn't make a difference, it's
okay, It has no meaning
for our actual plot there,
because we're squaring it, so
it doesn't matter whether it's
negative or positive, all that
matters is the magnitude.
But when we're thinking about
actual wave behavior of
electrons, it's just important
to keep in the back of our
head that some areas have
positive amplitude and some
have negative.
So we'll talk about this more
we get into p orbitals and
bonding is where it's going
to become an issue.
So I just want to kind of
introduce that idea here.
Because if we think about wave
behavior of electrons and
we're forming bonds, then what
we have to do is have
constructive interference of 2
different electrons, right, to
form a bond, we want to and
together those probabilities.
So we want to have constructive
interference to
form a bond, whereas if we had
destructive interference, we
would not be forming a bond.
So that's where you have to
think about whether it's
positive or negative.
You don't have to think about
it right now, but you might
have heard in high school
talking about p orbitals, the
phase, sometimes you mark a p
orbital as being a plus sign
or negative sign.
Did any of you do that in
high school at all?
A little bit, yeah.
So, that's having to do with
the actual wave function.
So, that'll become more relevant
later, bonding
actually, a couple lectures
down the road.
But I just want to introduce it
here while we do, in fact,
have the wave function
plots up here.
But a real key in looking at
these plots is where we, in
fact, did go through
zer and have this
zero probability density.
We call that a node, and a node,
more specifically, is
any value of either r, the
radius, or the two angles for
which the wave function, and
that also means the wave
function squared or the
probability density, is going
to be equal to zero.
So, we can see in our
1 s orbital, how
many nodes do we have?
There's no nodes, yeah.
It looks like we hit zero, but
we actually don't -- remember
that we never go all the way
to zero, so there's these
little points if we were to look
really carefully at an
accurate probability density
plot, it would never
actually hit zero.
And then, for example, how many
nodes do we have in the 3
s orbital? two.
That's correct.
So we have two nodes
in the 3 s orbital.
We can actually specify where
those nodes are, which is
written on your notes.
For the 2 s orbital, at 2 a
nought, so it's just 2 times
that constant a nought, which
is the Bohr radius.
And for the 3 s, we
have one at 1 .
9 a nought, and one at 7 .
1 a nought.
We can also specify what kind
of node we're talking about.
We'll introduce in the next
course angular nodes, but
today we're just going to be
talking about radial nodes,
and a radial node is a value
for r at which psi, and
therefore, also the probability
psi squared is
going to be equal to zero.
So, when we're talking about an
s orbital, since there is
no angular dependence, and it
only depends on r, every
single one of our nodes is
actually going to specifically
be a radial node, right,
because these are, for
example, this 2 a nought is a
value of r, a value of the
radius, no matter which way you
go around at which there's
going to be a node at which
there is zero probability
density of finding an
electron there.
So, it's very easy to calculate,
however, the number
of radial nodes, and this works
not just for s orbitals,
but also for p orbitals, or d
orbitals, or whatever kind of
work of orbitals you
want to discuss.
And that's just to take the
principle quantum number and
subtract it by 1, and then also
subtract from that your l
quantum number.
So what you can do for a 1 s
is just take 1 minus 1 and
then l is equal to 0, so you
have zero radial nodes.
And that matches up
with what we saw.
If we try this for the 2 s,
we have 2 minus 1 minus 0.
So what we should expect to see
is one radial node, and
that is what we see here in the
probability density plot.
And then if we think about 3 s,
we want to start with 3, we
subtract 1, again l is equal to
0, so minus 0 and we have
two radial nodes.
So, this should be pretty
straight forward, let's see if
we can get close to a 100% on
this one, which is how many
radial nodes does a
4 p orbital have?
And let's give 10 seconds
on that, make
you think fast here.
OK, so most people were
correct, or well, the
majority, at least,
were correct.
And seeing that it's a 4 p has
two nodes -- let's just write
this out since not everyone
did get it correct.
So, if we're talking about a 4 p
orbital, and our equation is
n minus 1 minus l, the principle
quantum number is 4,
1 is 1 -- what is l
for a p orbital?
STUDENT: 1.
PROFESSOR: 1.
So, I tricked you a little, I
guess I didn't put an s up
there and that's what we had
been talking about, so that
was probably the issue.
But what we find is that we
have two radial nodes.
All right.
So we can switch back
to our notes here.
So, doing those probability
density dot graphs, we can get
an idea of the shape of those
orbitals, we know that they're
spherically symmetrical.
We're not going to talk about p
orbitals today, we're going
to talk about p orbitals
exclusively on Friday, and as
I said, d orbitals you'll get
to with Professor Drennen.
But we can also think when
we're talking about wave
function squared, what we're
really talking about is the
probability density, right, the
probability in some volume.
But there's also a way to get
rid of the volume part and
actually talk about the
probability of finding an
electron at some certain area
within the atom, and this is
what we do using radial
probability
distribution graphs.
And what that is the probability
of finding an
electron in some shell where we
define the thickness as d
r, some distance, r,
from the nucleus.
So, think about what
we're saying here.
We're saying the probability of
finding an electron at some
distance from the nucleus in
some very thin shell that we
describe by d r.
So if you think of a shell, you
can actually just think of
an egg shell, that's probably
the easiest way to think of
it, where the yolk, if you
really maybe make it a lot
smaller might be the nucleus.
And let's also make our egg
perfectly symmetric and
perfectly round.
But still, when we're talking
about the radial probability
distribution, what we actually
want to think about is what's
the probability of finding the
electron in that shell?
Think of it as that
egg shell part.
So, we can do that by using this
equation, which is for s
orbitals where the radial
probability distribution is
going to be equal to 4 pi
r squared times the wave
function squared, d r.
That should make sense to us,
because when we talk about a
wave function, we're talking
about a probability divided by
a volume, because we're
talking about
a probability density.
So if we actually go ahead and
multiply it by the volume of
our shell, then we end up just
with probability, which is
kind of a nicer term to be
thinking about here.
So, of course, if we're talking
about a perfectly
spherical shell at some
distance, thickness, d r, we
talk about it as 4 pi r squared
d r, so we just
multiply that by the probability
density.
We can graph out what this is
where we're graphing the
radial probability density as
a function of the radius.
And what you see is that at
zero, you start at zero.
And so, the radial probability
density at the nucleus is
going to be zero, even though
we know the probability
density at the nucleus is very
high, that's actually where is
the highest. The reason in
our radial probability
distributions we start -- the
reason, if you look at the
zero point on the radius that
we start at zero is because
we're multiplying the
probability density by some
volume, and when we're not
anywhere from the nucleus,
that volume is defined
as zero.
So, it's a little bit artificial
that we're seeing
that zero point there.
So, actually I want you to go
ahead in your notes and circle
that zero point and write "not
a node." This is not a node
because a node is where
we actually have
no probability density.
So this, where we start at zero
is not a node, is the
first thing to point out.
And as we get further and
further from the radius, the
volume we're multiplying it by
actually gets bigger and
bigger, because you can see how
the volume of that little
thin shell is going to get
larger and larger as you get
further away.
So there's some distance where
the probability of actually
finding an electron there is
going to be your maximum
probability.
And that's what we label
as r sub m p, or your
most probable radius.
This is the point at which your
probability is highest
for finding an electron.
This is equal to a sub nought
for a hydrogen atom, and we
remember that that's just our
Bohr radius, which is 0 .
5 2 9 angstroms. And basically,
what that means is
you can actually find an
electron anywhere going away
from the nucleus, but you're
most likely to find that you
have the highest probability at
a distance of a sub nought,
or the Bohr radius.
So, I said I'd tell you a little
bit more about where
this Bohr radius came from, and
it came from a model of
the atom that pre-dated quantum
mechanics, and Neils
Bohr is who came up with the
idea of the Bohr radius, and
here is hanging out with
Einstein, so he had some
pretty good company
that he kept.
And what you need to remember
when we're thinking about this
model of the atom is that in
1911 it had already been
discovered that we have an
electron, and we have a
nucleus, and there needs to be
some way that those two hang
together, but it was not for
another 15 years that we
actually had the Schrodinger
equation that allowed us to
understand the interaction fully
between the electron and
the nucleus.
So all that Bohr, for example,
had to go on at this point was
a more classical picture of the
atom, as you can see on
the left side of the screen
there, which is the idea that
the electrons actually somehow
just orbiting the nucleus.
And even though he could figure
out that this wasn't
possible, he still used this as
a starting point, and what
he did know was that these
energy levels that were within
hydrogen atom were quantized.
and he knew this the same way
that we saw it in the last
class, which is when we viewed
the difference spectra coming
out from the hydrogen, and we
also did it for neon, but we saw
in the hydrogen atom that
it was very discreet energy
levels that we could observe.
He knew the same thing
that had been
observed by that point.
So, what he did was kind of
impose a quantum mechanical
model, not a full one, just
the idea that those energy
levels were quantized on to the
classical picture of an
atom that has a discreet
orbit.
And what he came out with when
he did some calculations is
that there's the radius that he
could calculate was equal
to this number a sub nought,
which is what we call the Bohr
radius, and it turns out that
the Bohr radius happens to be
the radius most probable
for a hydrogen atom.
And the reason we won't talk any
more about this Bohr model
is because, of course,
it's not correct.
So we're not going to spend
too much time on it here.
But we can see, for example, one
reason or one way in which
is not correct.
Because what it tells is that we
can figure out exactly what
the radius of an electron
and a nucleus are
in a hydrogen atom.
That's a deterministic way of
doing things, that's what you
get from classical mechanics.
But the reality that we know
from our quantum mechanical
model, is that we can't know
exactly what the radius is,
all we can say is what the
probability is of the radius
being at certain different
points. so, that's a more
complete quantum mechanical
picture of
what is going on here.
So if we superimpose our
radial probability
distribution onto the Bohr
radius, we see it's much more
complicated than just having
a discreet radius.
We can actually have any radius,
but some radii just
have much, much smaller
probabilities of actually
being significant or not.
So, I think we're a little bit
out of time today, but we'll
start next class with thinking
about drawing radial
probability distributions
of more than
just the 1 s orbital.